live this is a little unfortunate this
experiment goes like
this we're going to have to figure this
out a little
bit let me get set up
here and we're going to look at all the
uh the experiment results
oops I'm going to kill this because this
is not working and it's eating all the
memory let's see what we have here
this was definitely promising
stuff right
this one looks even better than that but
it
doesn't converge the same it looks
like and this one has been still
training and look if you see it was here
before
and I wasn't sure if I should have done
0.0 I probably just should have done
thats
there that'll run
I think this is zeroed right yeah this
is zeroed
you know it is interesting that they are
selling
stuff and they're buying stuff as
well
H there is actually Market use going
on that's pretty
cool so I mean this thing is
working I would really like to
understand though what is going on
with with this discrepancy right here
right
how was it working compared with
previous well it's better than Adam mu's
doing great we're just looking at psgd
and if we can get this to do better than
muan here let me show you
this so this is muon right here that's a
clean learning curve right that's a
really clean learning curve it's just a
log just straight up a log function
but then I'm trying psgd and you can see
if I go uh zoom in here right it looks
really promising and then it intersects
and it's done that with basically every
one of the experiments so far
consistent they just say sweep more
hyper
prams and like they're probably
right we do need to just sweep more
hyper prams
the runs are kind of expensive you know
they take a while to go I tried to do
these last night and uh the Run crash
partway through I mean you can see
like there's a lot of variant in
graph maybe one of these guys will
um figure this piece
right that's going to take forever to
run so we're going to have to figure out
some stuff to do in the
meanwhile um I think I'm just going to
go through some of my thoughts on what
I've been doing with this optimization
stuff lately
and maybe some of the remaining problems
so I was looking at a whole bunch of
different
techniques for just general purpose RL
improvements right like how do we
modernize uh the RL stack and I don't
mean like add a bunch of fanasy tools I
mean like why don't we go check out the
optimizers that llm people have been
using for the past while right why don't
we go check out like the learning rate
schedules for inance nobody uses linear
learning rate Decay they use cosine and
kneeling all right so I grabbed a few
things like
this
and I think the optimizer was the
biggest one but the other ones
definitely helped as
well and basically
overnight uh the breakout speedrun time
was cut in
half
and every single environment is is
essentially solvable now with the same
set of parameters not optimal mind you
uh but pretty much way way way more
hyperr stability than
before definitely not optimal so bigger
problems you're still going to want
stuff
tuned so then I was looking at okay well
what can we do from here cuz there's
still a few things that are a little bit
janky um
first of all I wanted to say okay can we
make the learning rate pretty stable
because that parameter usually varies
with model size had a long conversation
with the optimization folks and uh
looked at the math and yes it turns out
that actually any of these new
optimization methods are going to give
you invariant learning rate with respect
to model size so that's M what that used
to do this is kind of just built in now
which is really really
nice um
now there are a few additional sources
of need to change hyper parameters per M
right one is that some Ms just have way
way way more of a gradient noise than
other
Ms that's something to look
at and uh that requires you to use you
know larger mini batch size or lower
learning
rate in order to solve the same task
and then uh the other
one uh the other one is effective
Horizon which you know possibly these
could be related as
well but gamma and Lambda the GAE
parameters now it's interesting that you
know stuff does kind of work
um with the same set of
frams on a lot of different
mends um but there were there was at
least one where I had to change it to
make that work and ideally we wouldn't
have Gamma or Lambda at all so that's
what I was doing with
P30 so I think what we're going to do
today
then I have a couple of environments to
play with that I need to like start
getting some more results on with
puffer um and then I also I just want to
play around with p3o with the new
Optimizer stuff to see if it makes it
work better
now because it should be a lot easier to
experiment now that the hyper parameter
should be a fair bit more
robust we should be able to make some
progress and then in the meantime you
know these experiment will run in the
background
so I guess then today we'll look at
gradient
noise we'll look at P30 run a few
experiments on that we'll look at that
new environment and we'll see where we
get from there and sounds like a
plan me move this off to where I can
keep tabs on it
works and I believe this learning rate
is too high for it as well isn't it
Run
oh okay
let me go check what the default
learning rate
so this learning rate should be way too
high by
uh by those standards
it doesn't completely fail though which
is interesting even with like a
ridiculously high learning rate for this
algorithm
okay something's wrong then with these
defaults because uh this was working
really really well
before about
so everybody tells me to drop the
preconditioned learning rate I'm pretty
sure though I had uh I had it in the
sweep
the hell is this plasticity
sweep the hell is this plasticity annoyance that everybody keeps talking
annoyance that everybody keeps talking
about
do I have to actually go look at this
stuff oh hey Captain uh Dev Branch
attempting to train impulse
Wars what should I set F I never set
that
variable should not have to mess with
that for
I'm getting that when trying to load new
Cuda files yes you are I tell you what
you're
missing so are you on puffer
okay so I can show you you you don't
have the right version of Cuda um let me
show
you it's not a pip
package so if you even if you're not
going to use this if you just look at
our files once in a while in here uh you
need the Cuda developer uh you need Cuda
development
version without Dev you can't build um
you can't build like the new extensions
and
stuff though I don't actually know why
that would be a problem in your case if
you're not if you don't have like our
advantage estimation
stuff but this is what we have at the
moment yeah you can probably get like
Cuda Dev or whatever I have to see the
exact error
yeah so something weird happened here
because
the learning rate
there oh it's because break out has its
own learning rate I'm
dumb
there so this does
work we'll double check this
maybe we do need
L2 maybe we do need
nothing private with these
DMS be more interesting than me just
like sitting here typing stuff on the
side
something like pre-training for any epox
in the first 50 class from fine tuning
on
51 it learned but it never reaches the
same
accuracy or loss
fortunately this doesn't seem to work
either
m
I'm trying to think what we do with that
under the hoping this isn't some dumb
nerd snipe like exploration is but it
seems like this is potentially
legitimate at least it's
23385 I just want to see if the hypers
are like way different
entropy oh this thing is screwing with
the value coefficient completely isn't
it this thing is like totally screwing
with the value coefficient
I mean that shouldn't work
though that shouldn't
work if that does work then that tells
us there's a big problem
crashed zero oh that's going to just grw
up the value function I guess
this is not even training a value
function so what does that even do
I mean this should just basically be
reinforced
right yeah this has got to just be
reinforced it's interesting though
because um I think GAE without a value
function doesn't give you reinforce I'm
going to have to look at
that the fact that that does better it's
concerning okay I'm I'm going to be back
in a little bit here I'm going to think
about this I'll be back I don't know 5
10 minutes whatever I do a couple quick
things and uh we will definitely look
more at this algorithm and see what we
can do about
it right
okay let's first see if
uh our sweep is still
working looks like it
kind of crazy to reinforce out of the
box basically reinforce will do
uh 3 400
score well I mean I know for sure that
uh you can get way higher score with
this
algorithm question is
why it should need to be tuned
look yeah so it was this run right here
with this pretty low value function
coefficient and I wonder if there's
something to
that you know maybe there is actually
something to that it has a whole bunch
of different heads on
it I just want to see if this learns
better than before
there might be something about like slow
learning
value I mean and other than that
like slight entropy
difference but we have what we have
entropy 01 yes see these are like all
pretty
dang reasonable
defaults what did we get this is Lambda
Gamma 996 and
try yeah hang on I know the other thing
we can try
here yeah so there's nothing magic about
um like small but nonzero value function
coefficient it's just
weird so the other thing we
try um let's try
this with
muon or with uh what I
mean with just
PPL so this should now just turn into
like
interesting that this act looks like it
does way
worse it really is then the value
function
yeah what about um can I find like the
best best results I had on
this cuz I don't think that one was
particularly good
I guess this one
maybe this was probably the best two4
93 this is pretty well on par with the
PO solve time I believe before um before
mu
on so we should maybe be able to get
something out of
this 24 m
okay so there you see there is a
reasonable value function coefficient on
this a
point6 so I think what we'll do is we'll
try that
next could just be it could just be
something with the magnitude there
arm of
one that shouldn't matter these two
explicitly don't
it's better than before but still not
there
low clipping so gradient Norm shouldn't
matter learning rate of 05
do you think these could have different
learning rate
requirements the thing is it's just
default now it's literally just the
should be able to get something working
better than this at
least if this algorithm's any
good are we learning the value function
here let me see
yeah there a stupid green
one of
I don't want to just sit here manually
tuning hyper prams all day that's a huge
waste of
time but I do want to develop some
understanding
of of this problem and how we can fix
this thing
I mean this could literally just be as
simple as
retuning is the thing as
well I think the smartest thing to do
would just be to
like keep queuing up more experiments on
this stuff cuz there's just a lot of
stuff to
test I think the smartest thing is going
to be to just keep queuing up
experiments and then do the stuff I know
I can make progress on in the meanwhile
I'll let this one run though since we
already have this this just to see if
there's any
difference got impulse warning
on dev perf is same trying to bit slower
uh it's slower because the optimizer
muan has 10% overhead and uh cron has
about
20% they work way better
though I'd start with muan for now until
I figure out if there's something weird
weird with
cron okay well I can definitely convince
myself from this that the value
function uh the value function magnitude
is definitely important here let put 0.3
last experiment while I just think about
what else to do I think we're going to
probably want to do gradient
noise uh if we can do gradient noise
next that would be
if you put
import reduce overhead speeds up oh
perfect yeah that's what I wanted to
do that's what I was looking
for it's been annoying the hell out of
me
appreciated oh because I refactored that
thing
recently I have to fix that every time
you have to fix that every time you use
puffer because you haven't fully updated
yet I don't even think that's getting
imported as the
thing like if you look we don't use
these at the
moment right there used to be this
additional layer where you had to wrap
you had to wrap everything in this and I
got rid of that so I made the stack
thinner
I've been meaning to refactor those for
um compatibility with cleanar the idea
is that we make the main code path
simpler so that you don't have to wrap
anything in order to use our demo code
and then maybe you have to slightly wrap
something if you want to use it with
clean
RL don't use recurrent wrapper you just
use the um the lstm
wrapper you just directly use the lstm
wrapper now
it's easier
all right so what we're going to do for
this then
yeah that is what we found
Captain so this was the major
breakthrough
right I swept this with
breakout those uh those prams are
roughly tuned for
breakout and they work just about as
well as tuned atam on everything
else sometimes better sometimes a little
worse
you should definitely do a comparison
against uh you know your
original oh yeah
Captain can I see your uh your sweep
config real
quick I want to check
one thing I would
try just immediately and this is not a
good idea this is a hack until uh I
implement this correctly but just up
your mini batch size what do you have it
at right
now where's mini badge oh you already
have this massive never mind yeah then
this is
good um yeah but you can try to keep
this big mini batch
size uh I noticed with neural MMO it
doesn't seem to work on small mini
batches
what shouldn't shouldn't I sweep
over you can kind of sweep whatever I
have in the defaults if you want to it's
just a lot of stuff to
sweep um you still need to do gamma
Lambda entropy you still need the
learning rate's the biggest one probably
at this
point mini batch size is important uh
big batch size has been
helpful you know we have 500k default
mini batch has been useful for pretty
much everything you might just even want
to just keep
that we're also able to use more
environments now and Tim's training with
more m is
bother I think we did increase the BPT
Horizon
how do you compute the gradient over
multiple elements
Loop oh what's this n this doesn't work
either does it
3 how do you get it to work in a sweep
since the backat size
changes there doesn't seem to wait to be
a way to past custom ARS policies there
is if you just give if you just do
policies here
you
see if you just put a policy Block in
the any and you can put sweep as well it
just passes
it like there's not even an API for this
or anything it's literally you just put
stuff into the any file and you just
pass it in and you're
good I think what we're going to do for
the gradient stuff here is
just I can't actually do this I'm dumb
hold
on yeah I just I've been really dumb
there might be a square
root or might be
uh I see to easily pass bat size to the
policy based on what the sweep algorithm
suggested just in your demo code
right in your demo
code if you want to do
that
right ises this only get train
args well this has ARS args is hang on
make
policy yeah so you can just pass args of
train you can literally just do this
right args
train of what did you say batch size you
can just do this
14 Ram samples is 50 it's not 50
experiments though
if you look at the way we do it that's
five
experiments you get the entire
trajectory history at the moment so we
take the whole loss curve or the whole
training curve we uh we subsample so we
get 10 samples from
it and then you give 10 samples per
experiment to protein
wanted to make it the number of
pams uh yes assuming that you actually
have my sub sampling code because you do
have a custom demo file
because it was originally demo. because
it was originally just
demo and changing the name of the main
file too often pisses people
off so we might change it for next
release I mean what should I call it
inflate
is it this
slow the
oh train mini bats you
dummy yeah
dummy there we
Neptune and then get a run of this and
then we'll try neuro main dopie I don't
know sounds
looks like it has way lower variant
right long
does what other end should I use for
this snake
and then we try neural MMO and we see
the questions going to be if um gradient
variance lines up with like rough
perception of
that solves really really fast now
doesn't it
Let It Go for a little longer cuz I know
the training Dynamics are kind of
interesting for this
I wonder if they had uh reports for some
of their Ms I think that they
well there was a huge amount of gradient
noise at the start right there for a
second
starting to optimize a little bit so
we'll see if uh that translates to
gradient noise going back
up I guess it's gradient noise is low
because it's just not finding anything
for a while
well the other thing here with this
prediction is that
um you should be able to train with
smaller batch size
right and lower learning
rate just getting around to fixing
projectiles projectile ABS 120
floats so
linear 128 torch Max
and then yeah concatenate to encoder or
whatever
yeah that would be the suggestion
this doesn't seem like a super clear
metric to me this gradient noise
scale I wonder if this is just a proxy
for reward sparsity
I guess with like muan in particular we
should be able to do some sort of
experiment to demonstrate bze mini bat
size and variance you would
hope that's a good thing to do
yeah the fact that this variance is so
low is odd to
me I mean the vast majority of these are
getting no reward though so this is
probably just a measure of sparity and
more than
any
anything
yeah that's
interesting so I don't know about this
as a this gradient variance is a a
useful
measure I mean it's nice to log but I
don't know if it just tells you much on
its own know
I think it is
increasing but the scale is very
low oh wait unless did I do this
wrong on times mini batch size
yeah this is correct it should be times
mini bat
size so yeah the gradient scale doesn't
I mean it is increasing
I'll let this run a little longer just
because it's going to increase pretty
quickly maybe here but like the absolute
scale doesn't seem to have anything to
do with the task difficulty and
definitely is not predictive of the um
backat size that you would
need it's a little odd that they
actually found that in that it works
because I don't see it
here I suppose it could be that this
just increases very high over the course
of training if you train a good
model so at least I can confirm that
result that for some environments or
many environments it looks like uh the
gradient noise does increase over the
course of training
the actual magnitude is lower than the
magnitude of breakout
Noise by a lot
I wonder if there is any theoretical
basis then for
like if you made the gradient
accumulation proportional to the
variance
the problem is
like I think gradient variant zero could
either mean that you have a perfect
well I think you also have no gradient
variance if you're stuck and aren't
getting any
reward
right yeah then you have no signal so I
think that this thing is kind of brittle
okay let's try a couple just quick
experiments on
breakout so I want to test some
stuff I want to see if we can
actually uh get
the behavior that we predict in
1024 I'm going to see if this curve
matches
and there is still potentially a little
more Jitter right in the smaller
updates though they should be matched
for the most part they should
match and then we're going to check
we're going to check a few things around
the learning right here
so when they say really big batch size
is essential
oh wait do they have something on
learning right
here do they just use the same learning
rate
okay so we get to 790 which is not quite
as
good a little bit of a gap
there now what we do
is go back to the original earn rate run
this again keep looking at the
paper not this one for the paper
go think I'm doing something wrong there
are 30 projections with four
floats there are 30 projectiles with
four floats per projectile Ops
in that case 128 seems really
high for an input of
four well yeah and that's where it can
be potentially slower um the issue that
you're going to run into though is it's
not just 128 for an input of four 128 is
the total embedding Dimension that
you're going to compress all those
projectiles
into right so it's actually 120 going
into
128 it could be that this is very slow
and then we have to fiddle with
something
so I mean this does not behave perfectly
predictably
so I'm pretty sure this is
wrong this is what I used as my uh I
used this as a for a very very long time
but recently I took another look at GAE
and I think it's really gamma time
Lambda maybe it is gamma it's hard to
say from the
okay so we have our
new
ah so this actually
matches this matches the original pretty
well right
okay but this is half the number of
gradient updates as well
right so would be like Kish was it
halfway to here is 40 so it would be
right there these match very
96 need to try to puffer
box my desktop doing this drops 100K
SPS well yeah a lot of encoders
right um You can try 64 for
instance I mean the alternative right
the alternative would be you do some
pre-processing on them you know you'd
have to like order them or sort them or
or
something cuz right now it doesn't know
what like it's got to learn what
projectiles wear as well
oh look at
that so we'll see whether in wall clock
this is better but look at that in
okay another version of this
right another version of this is just
that the learning rate doesn't vary
linearly right
like there should exist some learning
rate for which smaller batch does better
than bigger batch
speed question is fast
compile is fast compile that much
different than
normal when
testing M Speed wa what is fast
compile I is that much is fast compile
that much different I have the 6X yes
that's completely normal
Spencer so
basically
like you know how in Python if you try
to access an element of an array that's
out of bounds you get an
error and like there a whole bunch of
safeguards like that so those compile
Flags inject all that stuff into
C so you essentially have like a modern
site like safe language right
but it's way
slower and there's not really any effort
to make those checks fast either because
it's meant for debug mode
kind of very a little right these like
vary a
bit I don't see like a clear Trend
better let see how this goes longer
term but still doesn't seem like it's it
doesn't seem like you get anything out
of the smaller mini badges
right that could be related to other
properties of the optimizer
though right maybe it holds for SGD only
or whatever
though I did a about on pars the one
where we just kept the learning rate the
same
bot full block list of twitch Bots at
this point
thought for a while M was way slower
because I was only checking speed on
debug
yeah that'll
happen I added the compile Flags like I
added those modes for a reason right not
just to show
I think I got to implement gradient
accumulation
next is what I've got to do because
um yeah right here this
is this is kind of showing me that mini
batch does not behave exactly the way
that you would
expect you know
you always get better
results a per step
basis so there is a critical size it
seems and what they were calling a
critical batch size is really a CR
critical mini batch
size and then batch size to mini batch
size gives you salness
oo okay I see how this
is time is it
11 I think what I'm going to do is I'm
going to go think about this for a bit
I'm going to get some exercise in get
some food and then we're going to come
back we're going to implement gradient
accumulation and we're going to try that
out so that'll be a new
feature and uh let me just make sure
that these other sweeps are still
running correctly
these have crashed a bunch of times and
it's a total pain they seem like they're
good this time
though see do we have anything
cool oh yeah we've got some cool stuff
here look at that
boom first run that beats uh first few
runs actually that beat the
previous previous winner
this is still nice and steep as well up
here so we'll keep going on this for a
little
bit what did this run do
differently didn't drop like M's or
something M this is good
yep fixed gamma
Lambda Max Mini batch size you can see
right
here change precondition learning
rate drop this by a factor of
two learning rate's pretty near the
default it's upped it by a little
bit a few other things but this is like
reasonable I'm happy with
that okay cool
yeah I'm going to go uh get my exercise
and stuff and then we will uh we'll see
where we go from there so for the couple
folks
watching buffer. for all my stuff here
you want to follow all this
reinforcement learning
Dev Go Star the repo on GitHub really
helps us
out other than that you can join the
Discord to get involved Dev and follow
me on X for more content thanks